ce soir j'aimerais partager une
expérience avec vous une expérience très
simple que vous pouvez mener avec votre
enfant ou votre élève
s'il est en bas âge et amateurs de
chamallows placez le dans une pièce
isolée face à une table et sur sept
tables disposées une assiette et dessus
un chamallow puis vous lui indiquez que
vous absenter quelques minutes
et si lorsque vous revenez le chamallow
est toujours en vie s'il a réussi à
résister contre sa gourmandise
il aura le droit à un deuxième chamallow
je sais ça ressemble à une petite
torture mais je ne suis pas qu'un
pensionnaire
cette expérience a été menée sur des
milliers d'enfants aux quatre coins du
globe dans les années 60 et les enfants
qui ont réussi à résister contre un peu
dire immédiat up gober un chamallow tout
de suite pour avoir une gratification
futur plus importante
manger de chamallow eh bien ces enfants
se sont avérées avoir une meilleure
réussite scolaire être en bien meilleure
santé et plus généralement avoir mieux
réussi dans leur vie mais qu'est ce qui
se cache derrière le secret du chamallow
pour expliquer une telle différence
d'éducation et de vie
répondre à cette question c'est
justement l'essentiel de ma recherche
je suis professeur d'économie à sciences
po
porté par j'ai pas dit d' insulte on
peut être professeur d'économie à
sciences po et être passionné
d'éducation ces mots cas et depuis des
années avec différentes équipes en
france aux états unis au canada
nous allons sur le terrain pour
comprendre quel est le succès de la
réussite scolaire nous allons aussi bien
dans des écoles avec un très fort taux
de harcèlement et de violence qui
empêche tout résultats scolaires
nous allons aussi dans des collèges où
vous avez un grand nombre de décrocheurs
ou encore dans des banlieues avec des
jeunes chômeurs entre 18 et 25 ans qui
sont isolées complètement socialement
depuis des années et à chaque fois nous
utilisons la même méthode
une méthode scientifique emprunté à la
médecine où nous tirons au hasard un
groupe d'élèves une partie méthodes
pédagogiques traditionnel uniquement
centré sur l'intellect
c'est la méthode placebo et l'autre
partie recevra des méthodes pédagogiques
plus innovantes
le résultat de nos recherches et
spectaculaire et ce résultat est
corroboré par l'ensemble des recherches
actuelles
quel est il le secret du succès scolaire
ne réside pas dans votre cuits ils ne
résident pas non plus dans vos capacités
intellectuelles il réside dans une autre
composante qu'on appelle des compétences
non cognitive
alors qu'est ce qui se cache derrière ce
mot barbare compétences dont cognitive
a priori deux dimensions la première
c'est justement l'effet chamallow c'est
votre ténacité votre capacité d'auto
discipline
votre capacité à avoir un projet une
stratégie et de vous y tenir
par exemple nous allons dans des
collèges pour essayer de lutter contre
le décrochage scolaire
à quoi sert-il de rajouter des heures de
mathématiques des heures de latin des
heures de français si le principal
problème de ces jeunes décrocheurs et de
pouvoir se concentrer de ne pas avoir
deux méthodes d'apprentissage qui leur
permettent justement d'apprendre ce que
nous évaluions ces deux nouvelles
méthodes qui leur apprennent à se
concentrer en ayant par exemple une
posture corporelle en classe ou
lorsqu'ils rentrent à la maison de
pouvoir différer un plaisir immédiat de
regarder tout de suite à télévision ou
de faire un jeu vidéo et
se concentrer pour faire leurs devoirs
et cette capacité d'auto discipline
cette ténacité c'est un vrais muscles
ans et elle se développe à tout âge
pas comme le cui qui se développe plus
après l'âge de 9 ans vous pouvez par
exemple le premier jour demandé à
l'enfant de se concentrer cinq minutes
pour faire ses devoirs avant de se
précipiter devant la télévision puis le
lendemain 10 minutes puis un quart
d'heure jusqu'à ce qu'ils développent
une véritable colonne vertébrale
ces disciplines on lançait n'y aussi
j'ai des jeunes chômeurs en rupture de
ban on a tout essayé
ils ont été de nombreuses fois dans des
reprises d'insertion éducative sur les
bancs de l'université
rien n'y fait vous avez de nouveaux
types d'éducation ou d'associations qui
leur proposent des projets innovants
tels que la création d'entreprise
pendant un an ils doivent réaliser un
grand projet alors bien sûr tous ne
deviendront pas des bill gates c'est pas
parce qu'on est chômeur en seine saint
denis ont nécessairement un bill gates
en puissance mais au moins pendant une
année
ils auront appris à développer un projet
à avoir confiance en eux et à se lever à
des horaires fixes pour rencontrer leurs
banquiers pour rencontrer leur chef de
projet jusqu'à ce qu'il développe une
véritable colonne vertébrale
la deuxième compétence essentielle pour
expliquer la réussite scolaire est ce
qu'on appelle les compétences sociales
compétences sociales c'est à dire
apprendre à coopérer à se parler les uns
les autres
ça vous semble simple et pourtant nous
en sommes tous largement démunis
d'ailleurs la première fois où j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser aux compétences
sociales a essayé à les mesurer
scientifiquement au moins essayer faire
se peut c'était lors d'une expérience
peu banale
c'était sous la présidence nicolas
sarkozy monsieur le président avait
décidé de créer une commission
comment vivre ensemble en 2050 en france
à l'époque nicolas pense être encore
président en 2050 il avait mis autour de
la table tous les plus éminents
chercheurs du monde entier en
neurosciences en psychologie en
sociologie même en économie avec moi
pour essayer de trouver le secret des
compétences sociales et du vivre
ensemble
et alors là tous ces éminents
spécialistes de la coopération réunis
pour bâtir un futur meilleur se sont mis
au bout de deux minutes à s'invectiver
alors le sociologue disait aux
psychologues mais tu n'as jamais rien
compris à la psychologie d'éducation et
après le psychologue disait ah si un
sociologue savait ce que c'était que
l'éducation ça se saurait et alors sans
parler des chercheurs en sciences de
l'éducation au secours finalement cet
exemple résume très très bien l'échec de
notre système scolaire voilà les plus
brillants esprits
réunis autour d'une table mais qui
n'avait qu'une tête et qu'il n'avait
jamais appris à avoir un corps et à se
parler les uns les autres
pour ma part je suis vraiment
impressionné surtout par le psychologue
celui qui avait été vraiment critiqué
par le sociologue ce psychologue avait
commencé dès le début des années 80 a
développé des compétences sociales chez
des jeunes enfants à montréal entre 6 et
8 ans qui était extrêmement isolées
socialement avec la mairie de montréal
et l'ensemble des enseignants et des
parents
il a identifié le groupe d'enfants le
cuisine ou le plus isolé puis a tiré au
sort parmi ce groupe une petite
composante qui a reçu en plus de
l'enseignement traditionnel un vrai
coaching sociale pendant deux ans ce
coaching social ça consistait à
travailler en groupe ou ce qu'on appelle
la médiation par les pairs
les pères pays rs c'est à dire apprendre
à travailler en groupe et surtout
apprendre la perspective de l'autre
encore mieux apprendre à deviner les
intentions des autres
il ya ne pas leur prêter
systématiquement des mauvaises
intentions comme on le fait tous
lorsqu'il m'a convaincu de prendre
l'avion et de retourner à montréal il y
a trois quatre ans pour suivre ses
enfants ses enfants étaient dans leur
quarantaine il me demandait d'évaluer
ensuite leur parcours professionnel
et là stupeur les enfants qui sont
passés par ce coaching sociale qui
étaient initialement en tout point
identique aux autres enfants de montréal
eh bien ces enfants avaient deux fois
plus de chances d'avoir reçu le bac est
quatre fois plus de chances d'avoir un
emploi et d'avoir un très bon salaire
vous voyez ténacité et autodiscipline
compétences sociales sont de compétence
non cognitive essentiel pour expliquer
la réussite scolaire et la réussite
d'une vie mais pas uniquement pour les
décrocheurs dont je vous parle pas
uniquement pour les enfants de banlieue
mais pour tous nos enfants pour tous nos
citoyens et même pour les personnes les
plus remarquables de notre société
je vous cite un exemple nelson mandela
nelson mandela avait coutume de dire ce
qui compte dans la vie c'est pas de ne
jamais avoir des chèques mais c'est
d'être capable après chaque échec de
pouvoir se relever et de pouvoir les
surmonter
alors comment est-ce qu'on forme amendée
lors on lui donne combien d'heures de
mathématiques
combien d'heures de français combien
d'heures de latin vous imaginez son prof
de maths à l'heure actuelle qu'il eut
marqué ben nelson
peut mieux faire la soute et
soustraction d addition elle dû sentir
mal après un elson mendy là c'est
quelqu'un qui développent de compétence
la ténacité la capacité à avoir un
projet un vrai projet d'humanité même
seul dans sa geôle et une compétence
sociale une capacité à fédérer
l'ensemble d'une société autour de lui
ses compétences sociales elles sont
essentielles pour apprendre à vivre
ensemble
mais elles sont aussi essentiels pour la
prospérité économique
pardonnez moi je reprends ma casquette
d'économiser quelques secondes
en effet à l'heure actuelle nous vivons
dans des sociétés que nous appelons des
sociétés de la connaissance des sociétés
d'innovation où chacun peut avoir une
bonne idée
vous savez tous on est tous créatif on a
tous des idées
le seul problème c'est comment s'assurer
que les entreprises laissent émerger ces
idées laisse émerger notre créativité
pour cela il faut que les entreprises et
des méthodes de management organisé de
façon très horizontale ou vous pouvez à
chaque fois laisser la libre circulation
des innovations contrairement à une
organisation très vertical anciaux
or seuls les pays comme les pays
nordiques qui investissent très tôt dans
une éducation coopératives ont des
entreprises avec une véritable
coopération entre les collègues
alors vous me direz si c'est si simple
que ça pourquoi n'at-on pas encore
réformé notre système scolaire
à mon avis deux raisons à cela une
raison simple la première c'est que pour
le moment on ne savait que mesuré le
cuit c'était la seule chose france avait
mesuré de façon relativement fiable or
cet obstacle est maintenant surmonter
on est capable de mesurer les
compétences sociales les capacités à
coopérer et même une organisation comme
l' ocde proposera maintenant des
questionnaires aussi bien tel que pisa
sur les compétences intellectuelles mais
aussi des questions sur votre
intelligence émotionnelle
le deuxième obstacle qui me semble
vraiment fondamental est plus une raison
économique
c'est que pendant très longtemps on
vivait dans des sociétés industrielles
organisé de façon pyramidale où
l'ensemble des produits étaient
relativement standardisés donc il
suffisait d'avoir l'ingénieur
l'x mines qui avait son idée et puis
l'ensemble des salariés ensuite contrôlé
ou effectuer les tâches dans notre
nouvelle société
ce n'est plus possible les sociétés
d'innovation nécessite maintenant une
organisation extrêmement horizontal et
pour pouvoir créer une société du vivre
ensemble où vous avez à la fois une
performance économique et une
performance sociale il faut commencer
très tôt par une école de la confiance
bonsoir